okay so that's the first little idea
finding a percentage of a quantity um
percentage of a quantity
is also something you looked at in
number skills but because we're in
um investing everything's going to be
money isn't it
okay so for instance if we wanted 72
percent
72 percent of
uh quantity quantity yeah
too small sorry all right all right
bigger all right bigger is it quantity
yes that's right uh 72 of any number you
like
so say you know uh what's the
most recent large purchase i had okay so
vacuum pretty classy vacuum that i've
bought was 850
okay so suppose suppose i only had to
pay i got a discount so suppose i only
had to pay 72
of that okay i'm going to use what i've
just looked at with my decimals here
because my button doesn't have a percent
button right but it does have decimal
buttons right so you see how these build
each other so i'm going to go 0.72
that's
72 as a decimal and i'll just multiply
by whatever that amount was and i don't
know what that is so let's just quickly
work that out
okay so you get 612. so that would be
612 dollars if i had all of my
units on there okay now do be careful
because we're
let me let me talk about um
rounding here because we looked at
rounding under number skills as well so
but suppose i had some weird awkward
percentage okay something like oh i
don't know
71.8 okay that's a really awkward number
isn't it okay
now if i take it of the same amount of
850
okay what would this look like well as a
decimal
what would 71.8 percent be
yeah nathan 0.718 good well done
um you've moved the decimal place twice
and that eight just trails along the end
okay now when i multiply that by 850
i'm expecting it's going to give me some
weird looking number let's try it
0.71 whoops
okay sorry see i get
six one zero point three is that okay
zero no point is that what you've got
zero point seven one eight times a fifty
okay
now six one zero point three is correct
for the calculator but it's not an
amount of money
isn't it because we don't say 0.3
cents or 0.3 dollars right so if i want
to save this as
a as a sum right i would need to say
610 and 30 cents
okay so they're little weird things that
are slightly between money
and decimals and percentages you have to
watch out for
okay one last thing suppose after you
got your calculated there right
suppose this number here was something
unusual
suppose sorry i shouldn't be using green
suppose it was calculator told us this
okay and it gave you a whole bunch of
numbers after that okay
because we're doing money right you
assume
you assume you round off to the nearest
two decimal places why two
because that's sense isn't it right so
this would be this would be equivalent
to
610 dollars and 34
cents you ran off to the nearest set
okay please be careful been recently
looking at um a lot of year 11 papers
and sometimes people see this and um you
know they automatically think oh you
know if i have to pay for this
this gets rounded off to the nearest
five cents doesn't it
so a lot of people will write 610.35
okay now if you're paying in in actual
cash
that is what you would have to pay right
but but this
is not this right this doesn't round to
this it's you've done something extra
because of money
um it's only if you're paying cash if
you weren't if you're paying credit
you wouldn't have to round it off to the
nearest five cents right
and again you know sometimes i see
people round off to the nearest nearest
ten cents
or to the nearest dollar and sometimes
people just pick it out at random okay
so just be careful there right so the
nearest cent
that's your default okay